holy tamale that was so intense I I mean
you're guarantee a little bit I uh all
right it was just a lot oh my God you're
the first person here I think he's
gotten so tense that they started
actually watering up
what is going on there
citizens so I don't know how to say
citizens in Spanish of the reject Nation
Jordan once again by Tara Erickson Tara
you've been coming here for the past few
weeks what is the one movie I've been
saying we should watch this and we just
never do wreck and every time he says it
I'm like wreck like
w-r-e-c-k and I always am like nope I
know what he means he hasn't stopped
talking about it here's a fun fact of my
life like annoying how much he talks
about it hold on one there's a fun fact
in my life Tara they remade this into a
movie called quarantine I saw quarantine
two the straight to DVD sequel but I
never saw wreck I need to watch this
film finally so here we are I hear it's
fantastic it's in Spanish so get ready
to put that American dog in there to the
test and read some stuff today adios I'm
excited ladies and gentlemen leave a
like also Tara what should they do
[Music]
ring the bell full-length Reaction watch
as long as we stick with your own copy
of wreck available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page become a
super section reject check out all the
stuff we cover they're exclusively
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included thank you to all of join me in
so many pledges because we've been
covering a ton of movie reactions so
thank you for your support are you ready
Tara to finally do this I am listo that
means estoy liso I'm ready really estoy
listo do you speak some Spanish what
let's turn off the subtitles
[Music]
and videos
what a huge microphone
that's tied on with a zip cord
oh my God it's like filming with Tara
one take wonder I don't know what you're
talking about
that sounds like a good time heck yeah
it's gonna be a fun hour yeah
they're apparently very good Cooks
you still want to be a firefighter
genuinely because of dinners like this
yeah it's one of the community community
experience
all right
this feels very real yeah
they have a bat the whole basketball
court there too
looks like it'd be so much fun to be a
firefighter this is camaraderie building
the whole time great dinners basketball
courts lots of movies
foreign
we got an alarm people we got an alarm
all right let's move will the cameraman
slide down too move move move
her character Arc is she's gonna not
care what she looks like uh
[Laughter]
a wreck oh well done
I wonder how much of this is improvised
yeah that's a good question because it
seems so very off the cuff and very
natural
oh damn okay
holy [__] instantly so fraught damn
wow this is intense they had camera guys
walking upstairs backwards
he's doing a very good job
I wish Michael Scott from the office was
here
I need to redo that take
spooky old lady
it does not matter
no thank you
oh my God
real sound designs
oh my God what is happening oh my God
oh my God
no I would not turn my back to her
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
damn well done oh my goodness
oh
yeah
oh damn
oh turn the camera light on what what
crazy frenetic energy
oh my goodness this is so intense this
is so real
[Applause]
[Music]
easy
everybody
quarantine
he doesn't know get him out of there
before he bites y'all
that's true
vote
this is so anxiety
what
what what what
I always spit out my drinks
oh
it was insane yeah the old lady's still
up there
yeah let the tape go buddy that's the
end of the movie terror
be careful that lady's throwing people
off the stairs this is remarkably shot
is she going back in the room yes and I
don't know why also where are the other
people
no oh my God no
what's up
what is that an infected person or a
turned person
she's dead she just oh God the old
lady's not dead that so yeah
okay do they just shoot her down yeah
what are the rules you have to get a
head shot she just could come back from
it somewhere in the back of her head
she's like
this is a good story yeah
she's gonna come up with a script and
then that lady is gonna get back up I
know it
oh I don't like it that's true there's a
toy review
oh god oh what do you why do you have to
see it yeah why yeah
her fever's gone up yeah because her dad
was out getting her antibiotics but he
can't get back in is that part of the
infection no no no she just had well
oh my God they cut off everything
don't go back up there
display
I can't tell if that's just what
Dreadful sound design or if there's
music
oh [__] God
what
whoa
oh my God no one cares man yeah he is so
not in charge
did he just pull out his gun
so impressive with the guy going on in
the background yeah
the choices and reactions feel so
authentic yeah
that the one who fell I don't know
oh my God
oh my gosh just cut through the needle
in the skies
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
this is so well crafted here like
whoever directed this and got these
people to every single one seemed like
it was like in the moment real is like
Bravo
[Music]
got himself already
I was waiting for that one guy
oh oh boy
this is
relatables
where is the fourth one
oh my God
oh my goodness everyone hears racist
against the Chinese or Japanese people
the responses and dialogues are so real
so vividly laid out I can't I am so
impressed I can't help but like Marvel
at how well crafted this is like you're
actually getting to know them
in a way that's not like Exposition
driven but just the way they're
responding to things
they do a lot with a little
it's faking like the time yeah it's like
television
oh
Oh that girl looks dead the best thing
you can do is kill the old man upstairs
and this little girl and her dog too
me that
yeah
[Music]
have they still not shown us Pablo no
that's Pablo's feet I think yeah yeah I
don't think we've actually seen his face
yet no
oh my God
[Music]
hey just wait to get the information man
just let him record later
kisses
lady I like you but please be quiet shut
the hell up yeah is that shot supposed
to kill him like put him down
oh yep you're in for it now oh my God
[Applause]
she's up too oh not that guy that guy
was great
everybody oh my God
oh my God get out of the way
if you know espresso saliva then let
them get out
wow
oh no sir you gotta kill that dog is
oh okay yeah you gotta put her down and
the mom oh come on they wouldn't know
oh this is poor mom and daughter
[Music]
damn it
wow
[Applause]
oh my God
oh the [__] father damn it oh
shootings
I don't get why you can't send in more
people to help there's not enough suits
Greg yeah they're low on suits damn it I
did not say a little girl attacking the
mom me neither and it was awesome
there's so much anguish in that moment
too like the mom getting hurt and then
realizing they're gonna try to take her
daughter
this apartment this one freaking room
what's the deal with this place
can I know you
know oh my God she's right there I can't
do not grab a weapon
let's just get a charge at you man
oh my god oh my god dude why is it the
guy with the Hazmat suit the one doing
it why isn't the guy with the Hazmat
suit
another money
because he's in charge
damn look at her forehead
[Music]
[Applause]
oh whoa
wow what Pablo is really getting a great
shot here
memories
oh that guy was all right in the end
oh my gosh he's alive oh my God
whoa nicely done
whoa that was scary
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
no no don't take them off
coward you're just gonna have to let the
mom die
I wanted to save her but it can't I mean
she was already gonna turn man
what the hell is that noise
God damn I hope Pablo makes out of this
alive
so chaotic this is just Wackadoo Wild
ER come on catcher
pull it together
oh yeah
filling that off
oh yes
close that weird gate kill him
damn
[Music]
[Applause]
it
where
foreign
come on
holy [__] this is
horrifying
this is a legitimately scary man this is
the most insane thing I have watched in
a minute
stop yelling you're going to draw
attention
no no not him
oh
yeah
[Applause]
does that do the trick all right does
that work
that's why she's cuffed
wow
but the camera now Pablo thank you Pablo
oh my God
shoot them
oh my goodness okay so they just become
like super rabid
what did they turn off the lights
[Applause]
oh my goodness
wow
[Applause]
oh my God
the Mallet oh God oh God do it hurry up
yeah all right okay
I'll wait here what
ah should mess up her mic
[Music]
just take them all
oh my God there's so many of them oh
he's right there oh
my God oh my God oh well you don't know
there's a million of them there's no way
there's absolutely no way you're gonna
oh my God she found it okay okay
foreign
oh God that is not a penthouse
oh this this is what started it
religious did he start some stuff with
all this Juju
God are those all he killed these people
what is this what what's going on here
yeah guns and [__] okay he's a sociopath
I mean it looks like some type of
Catholic Catholic thing again
possession possession
ah so it's not an infection it's a
demonic thing is
[Music]
there's like a whole like mythology to
this [__]
all right
just grab anything that could be a
weapon yeah like for sure like go in
with anything
[Music]
Yuri how do they experiment with putting
in the dog
I think so
[Music]
going to seal off the room okay seal
should keep her in don't break through a
seal
wait is that little girl the old lit no
oh my God
what is up there wait a minute
all you ever do is close it wait like a
half hour
oh this POV I can't stand it
oh boy this move is gonna give me a
freaking heart attack this might be the
scariest thing I've seen on this [__]
what's on this channel so far
so scared
[Music]
no uh
oh my God
foreign
y'all are dead that little girl gonna
kill y'all that was a little girl over
there boy it looks like a boy but like
they were talking about the little girl
so I don't know
I can't see
neither what is he even looking at what
that's a little girl
oh my God
this is a little scary
what no
[Music]
what does what is that what what is this
oh my God that's like some games
what the [__] oh
it's so lanky is that computer generated
or a real person because that is I can't
they're looking for a snack
s
oh no
oh oh
thank you take the cross as you walk out
maybe it will save you
oh she's a dum-dum
s
run where
oh my God
ah so she like
she like grew up
ah
[Music]
goodbye Angela
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wow
oh my god wow wow holy tamale oh my
goodness I've heard for years how great
that was
like damn that was so scary
that was so intense I've seen your
dinner a little bit damn damn Tara
uh you're right it was just a lot oh my
God
I'm glad you agreed to do this reaction
for free today
[Laughter]
oh boy
I feel tired like that was so much
anxiety fueling through my system that
my body is like
you you lie down now
you're the first person here I think
he's gotten so tense that they started
actually watering up a little bit I
gotta hear your thoughts man I mean this
Wackadoo wild one of the best horror
movies that I have ever seen I have not
seen that many it from 2018 I think that
was year 2017. I love that movie I'm
always like that's my favorite this I
know it's very different but this holy
junk the acting was Stellar I have never
seen
like that it's set up so well where
every single person is so very
believable
I just I don't know I mean this was so
believable I felt like I was there the
POV with the camera I I'm curious how
many rehearsals they had to do or how
much the director had to redirect to be
like no it still doesn't feel as real
yet or if he just found people that are
just perfect for what's happening all of
it was so believable and terrifying and
I need to know if that lady at the end
was computer generated or real because I
can't well it says digital I've mean
that doesn't I don't know I don't know
what these mean looking at these effects
here or the credits
yeah uh talk about a build
wow a great grip on pacing because it
starts out with that you know the or
just get it into just to think of where
how far we've come like ah we're just
documenting the firefighters fun little
cute evening new show segment we're
gonna do and the how it escalates
because it reaches this point
where
all houses starts breaking loose and
it's this crazy cacophony of events of
everyone turning you never know where
they're gonna come from and the movie
did such a good job at getting you
familiar with the layout of the building
and the and this The Limited space they
had but the floors as well so you had
some spatial awareness of what you had
to what you had to deal with with this
playground essentially
um but it it felt so claustrophobic and
yeah I mean that with found footage it's
especially with the found footage has
evolved into where they do like a lot of
cool hyper stylized things is they've
got to like up their game now this this
felt like they just got like a VHS
camera yeah like recording [__] yeah
that was that was because because so
much of it just seemed to rely on what's
in camera and for these very long takes
um with some brilliant sound design
throughout it and yeah I love how you
watch these characters essentially
because it's not one of those things
it's about like character Arch or
anything like that you just watch them
deteriorate over time and yeah lose
their minds and there's a sense of irony
of this I I don't really know if like I
don't think this Angelo girl deserved
what happened to her obviously not like
I don't think there is but it starts off
in the middle in the beginning of the
movie where you can see as being a
journalist is going on camera there's a
hint of like vanity behind uh the
performance but I feel like that's kind
of like for anyone who's on camera
you're gonna be aware of those things
especially for women
um but there seems to be like a bit of
an extra emphasis on that and and then
just getting like stripped down to her
core like starts off where it's all
about presentation and then how you're
seeing her I've heard
like deteriorating breakable vulnerable
stage ever back to her demise it's it's
so it's a wild film it's a very wild
film and [__] Terror I've seen so
many zombie movies and so many zombie
show and shows as well and to still be
this affected by something that is a
essentially part of the infected zombie
category I think is very impressive oh
gosh so impressive like and I just can't
get over how believable everyone was
like it everything it's just I don't
know everyone was so good in this
I started to get concerned like when the
firefighter got taken out and that
reveal of the stair
s like it's it's so well composed like
but that was but it doesn't feel like
I'm looking at a director doing this is
gonna be my cool cinematic shot but
there are a lot of like cool cinematic
shots but it never pulls you out of the
realism you know right because it's like
they showed that shot from like they're
kind of on the they just do a swoop and
you see like kind of just a a thud like
your brain just goes oh he came from
which they I guess maybe he just like
fell over onto the ground like I'm
trying to think in shooting wise but
like yeah because he could have been
like I'm sure but that would have taken
us out of it if he's shooting from like
up top and we see a guy falling it's
like a lot of these things are just cut
to swoot and there it is yeah there
which
um I I think you're right feeds into the
realism a lot because you can't really
actually catch those kills on camera too
well because it'll look too set up it
has to just be
realistic which I'm wondering that's
again why I'm wondering how many
rehearsals they had to do to go well if
the camera's here and they're shouting
how do we cut to like him being on the
ground to keep rolling and have it seem
all very just very real yeah it's they
keep you locked into the POV and I can
actually get on board with the cameraman
being so good at this because once in a
while I will get my you know nitpick
found footage brain that comes out of
would he just still keep recording I
feel like you get to a point where
you're just like you gotta like by your
side you're [__] running right yeah
um
however because they they put so much
emphasis
on they're trying to cut they're doing
something terrible to us yeah they're
not trying to protect us you have to
document we have to document it there's
so much emphasis on it he's a
professional cameraman who's such a
professional that he's trained himself
to observe solely through the lens uh of
the camera whereas like us the average
person would probably put the camera
down at any moment you know what I mean
like we just started running for it or
or not care to capture it but it's like
you get the impression this Pablo so I
thought it was smart to never see
Pablo's face because you get the
impression that he he is so trained to
the point where he oh he has to he his
vision is just he is the camera yeah he
becomes one with the camera as that kind
of camera operator that he is
um so I I was actually able to buy into
that because they had the the middle
section where it was slowing down quite
a bit when you are when she's like
interviewing the people you know yes
that was so necessary for the a the
crazy blowout yeah
wow what an impressive film and what
happened to the old people
um what do you mean we know the old lady
and the old I'm sure they're gone for
I'm sure they were one of the people
die though I know because they were oh
they were probably it's at the very end
when we saw like Pablo right where it
was like Pablo then all of them on the
stair well and they're all just coming
up for them right now the firefighters
I'm sorry not Pablo the firefighter yeah
who ran up and there he was and then all
the rest of them were coming at the
stairwell unreal
so fraught and like
yeah it's just it's so like it's it's
oppressive and so much anxiety and it's
a whirlwind of emotions like the part
that where I was where I found myself so
impressed with the emotionality was when
the mom got cuffed oh yeah so when she's
yelling Jennifer yeah because she's
she's she's just um like wailing in pain
because they know they're gonna like try
to take her little girl but she's also
suffering physically from what her
little girl just did to her yeah it's
like
fear trying to protect but also scared
and rage there's just so much emotion
being blasted through it just feels like
such a such a vulnerable experience for
everyone yeah it is so good so good I I
really love this and it's been hype for
me for so long that's why people want to
watch it and to be like wow I didn't
know this would be this good
I just thought it was going to be like a
well-made movie yeah this was amazing
and the cuts to Black did a lot of did a
good amount of work too like it didn't
seem like a cheat like oh they need to
cut out of that because like makeup
wasn't good enough or they couldn't do
that stunt or like they couldn't I don't
know it just it worked out that's like
when it cut to Black it just made sense
yeah
yeah it's a very long battery life those
cameras have you must have brought extra
batteries
yeah I did wonder why they couldn't get
like some people to go in there though
they were able to send one guy why
couldn't they send like a couple of
people to right and all soldiers or
whatever it is yeah swap people and even
with like the plastic I'm like oh yeah
they could just grab stuff break the
Windows like you can break through that
plastic of them if they were really if
they start to really lose it but then
you'd be scared that the police would
shoot you dead right they set it up to
where like there's so many sirens or
like you have to stay inside that you
kind of would be afraid that you would
maybe be shot which is the reason why
they weren't like blowing up to get
outside but
the whole time the people back there the
entire time great use of their budget so
good such a great way to do their budget
because you get this sense that there's
so much so much happening outside but
really in reality the problem
guy being like all right yeah yeah yeah
you had a great grip on harrowing
atmosphere that was so that was so well
done like it's it from from people who
like want to make our own [__] it it's
kind of inspiring in a weird way because
you're like oh damn like they did
something with so little yeah that was
so [__] effect like they rented out
this bill I mean obviously the fire
truck and traveling to that cost money
in the production yeah at the same time
it's mainly it's just it's mainly One
locations it's just this one building
yeah
um and then all that religious undertone
[__] at the anonymous it was just like
very very much apparent that I like the
ambiguity of of how it all went how it
all got there yeah was it it's like okay
was it a scientific infectious thing
that the Vatican
confused it for being demonic possession
right is it an inverse right the other
thing
well I mean she looked pretty demonic at
the end
like long and stretched out and the face
was it was
I can't it's the thing in nightmares as
I said Del Toro horror [__] oh
gnarly the only
the only one shot that I was like oh it
was so obvious that it was coming is
that when they set up the old guy by the
gate when the guy just said I've been
bitten he locks himself in he's like get
out of here right
it's so funny because you're like yeah
we all just saw that guy throw the keys
and we all know he's been bit but this
old guy is trying to tell him can you
hear me I get why they set it up that
like he they're like okay so how do we
get him there the guy doesn't hear you
so you have to grab him turn him around
towards you and now you're by the gate
can you hear me but I'm like uh I wish
because you know in that moment when
they set somebody up that close to the
gate that he's gonna come through the
gate again yeah that was the only thing
that I saw coming and I was like oh that
that was really the rest of it did girl
biting off her mom's face didn't see
that coming uh a guy falling that stare
thing terrifying also I really didn't
even see it coming when you when we have
the POV of the two
um already bitten guys on the table
you're kind of thinking like when they
give him a shot they're gonna get up but
it wasn't even that guy it like cut to
like they both got up same time and just
started like losing it and I didn't see
that coming it was yeah the movie knew
how to tour with your expectations and
then went to put you solely in the
camera POV of when like something would
just pop up in frame like when that old
lady who just the the first lady yeah
just doesn't die she just doesn't stay
down she doesn't die that was there when
she just popped in the fridge Oh I
thought that was so terrifying boy was
the scariest part for me I almost jumped
out of this chair yes I was so scared
that I was just frozen I had to like put
my hand over my chest I went over here
like was gonna fall over like I
even though you know it's like there's
got to be something coming I just
man this movie is this movie's great
that was a great movie it's really good
like if you want
it's it's the type of movie too that you
you want to like
show Friends to be like hey watch this
movie right like on Halloween like oh my
God it's this little like found footage
film it's funny like it's it's not even
in English like no big deal but if
they're paying attention it's gonna be
pretty terrifying like you can sell it
as like it's just like a fun little
thing but it's so it's spooky can you
imagine if we watch this with a lot with
no lights I was like oh this is already
like so such an experience
no I don't like looking around like oh
my God the lights are Robin's gonna be
way more scary terrifying yeah yeah I
mean but having the headphones on really
does help immerse with it that's why I'm
I really wanted to make sure we had
headphones uh for these kind of for
reactions because that helps offset some
of the light experience because the
sound pulls you in that's why I like the
volume up here I know he liked it up so
loud that's why there's two times yeah
it like hurt my ears but it pulls you in
I just want to see if wreck 2 is like
liked
yeah because I'm like how would you like
top like I want to see it
I feel like after this one if people are
liking it we're gonna have to do all of
them because why not
rec2 is 68 it's pretty good not as good
as this person
the First on Reddit is just as good if
not better
oh interesting I don't know there's such
a surprise Factor though yeah the Rotten
Tomatoes guys like not as good as its
predecessor yeah
okay 60 what did the first one have on
yeah
wreck
82. okay that's an audience quite a big
dip critics yeah huh
okay yeah that was a nightmare
[Music]
it really was I love that that was so
well done wow like whoa what a great
what an inspiring way to make a film
and for found footage this is such a
genre that is like gawked at you know
people eye roll that at found footage
all the time right no this is a
cinematic experience right here that was
impressive
alrighty gang well what did you think
about wreck leave your thoughts down
below
let's see who the lucky one is he's
gonna get a shout out in this wreck
video today here we go Lance door Lance
if you were the perfect one to shout out
for this because I hate to bring this up
again homeboy is a firefighter oh
we just saw a movie where a firefighter
was saving the day the whole time so if
Tara and I were trapped in a situation
like this if I was Pablo who she was
Angela oh we would love for you to be
our maneu please come save us Lion's
door oh you'd be a perfect person to be
trapped in a situation with and watch
you kill a bunch of people while Tara's
panicking like a wild animal yeah I'm
like calm down woman calm down
great
[Music]
Ness
and Lance you would be there just to
yell at us silencio and I would love
that about you yeah you're more
masculine than I'll ever be and um and
then when uh the pandemic sweeps the
world of this virus infection and
there's only just you and Tara left you
two will have to repopulate the Earth
yeah I hope you're good looking
hahaha
he is
[Music]